[Music]
when I was deciding between Business
Schools one of the common refrains that
I heard from people who were students at
the GSB is how collaborative the culture
is I have been surprised and just
Overjoyed with how much my classmates
care about one another you can really
take the reins of your MBA experience
here they definitely equip us with all
the basics that you need for business
but there's an entire side to the GSB of
you getting to explore your passions and
really create your MBA your way members
of The Pride Community are people who I
go to for advice on an interview for
advice on how to handle like a personal
situation The Pride Community is the
place that I can go to because I know
they're always going to be there for me
it's some of my closest friends they're
the people I choose to be with the pride
Community is really special because
people are from any background you could
possibly imagine but who are all United
in this unconditional love that we have
for one another for me the pike
Community has been my family since day
one on campus and it's been really
wonderful to see those relationships
grow I've actually found the size of the
community to be quite large even though
we're a smaller class overall and I
think because of that the relationships
we get to build together are much deeper
The Pride Community really shows up for
each other and that started even before
we got on campus so whether it was
navigating through all the complications
of transitioning to a new place
understanding how to operate inside the
business school Community as part of
Pride we organize some events with
regards to allyship and education that
reach out to the broader GSB Community
The Pride Community is really active on
campus and to have those teach-ins
coupled with really fun social events
and ways to bring every person together
not only people who are in The Pride
Community who identify as lgbtqia but
people who are also questioning and
people who are thinking you know how can
I show up as a better Ally and advocate
in my mind that's what makes Pride
special I didn't have a lot of queer
role models to look up to and coming to
the GSB has given me not just one or two
but an entire community of people that I
know that I can reach out to with any
kind of a question that I have for me
one of the most powerful moments at the
GSB was during an event that we held
focused on the art form of drag and
talking about what drag means to the
lgbtq community especially in this day
and age where there's a lot of
misinformation and mistruths about what
it means to the lgbtq and how drag is a
part of our culture for me it was one of
the first times where I really felt like
my life as a queer person and my life as
a GSB student were overlapping in a way
that allowed me to be my full self in
front of all of my class business school
comes with a lot of stereotypes and
heteronormativity is one of them I've
been really pleasantly surprised by how
open everyone is and how ready they are
to not just engage but learn I would say
my recommendation to students who are
hoping to come to the GSB and be part of
the pride Community is tell your story
and talk about your intentions for
coming to the GSB I think my biggest
piece of advice is don't be afraid to
embrace your identity and how that's
driven you through your career I think
that can be really scary to put your
whole self on paper and to have to show
it to the admissions officers but what I
found is that the people here are so
wonderful including in the admissions
staff and they're looking to see who you
are and to really get an understanding
of you being lgbtq is about questioning
existing Frameworks it's about breaking
down the binary and I think getting to
bring that perspective not just to
interpersonal conversations but to
classroom discussions and to Business
Solutions has been really really fun and
something I'm really proud to be a part
of
[Music]
foreign